Katrina:  哈
Katrina: Ha
Nicous: 他咋跳的
Nicous: How did he jump?
Shure: 六
Shure: Six
Shure:  哈哈
Shure: Haha
Shure:  我曹这个他妈的
Shure: Damn this is f*cking
Shure:  跨肩膀肩膀跨
Shure: Cross shoulders, shoulders cross
Shure:  这几个关节好像2哒3哒45678哇
Shure: These joints are like 2 da 3 da 45678 wow
Shure:  还扎马步
Shure: Still doing horse stance
Shure:  哇
Shure: Wow
Shure:  张元英转圈是吧
Shure: Jang Won-young spinning, right?
Shure:  不行这真不会啊
Shure: No way, I really can't do this
Shure: 七八
Shure: Seven eight
Nicous: 我曹
Nicous: Damn
Tasha: 难度不对吧
Tasha: The difficulty isn't right, right?
Nicous:  So easy
Nicous: So easy
Shure:  这是0.5倍速是吗
Shure: Is this 0.5x speed?
Lucia: 卡了吧
Lucia: It's lagging, right?
Shure:  好心情哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Good mood, hahahahaha
Shure:  one two three four
Shure: one two three four
Shure:  one two three four 1234
Shure: one two three four 1234
Shure:  one fuck 23 哇吼
Shure: one fuck 23 wah-ho
Shure:  啊不行了不行了
Shure: Ah, I can't do it anymore.
Tasha: 先把前两部分
Tasha: Let's start with the first two parts.
Nicous: 今天到此为止吧
Nicous: Let's call it a day.
Choiszt:  再来一次
Choiszt: One more time.
Katrina:  把前两部分回顾一下
Katrina: Let's review the first two parts.
Choiszt: 我们只跳前两部的
Choiszt: We're only doing the first two parts.
Shure:  脑容量要炸了
Shure: My brain's about to explode.
Katrina:  手机呢调往前调一下
Katrina: Where's the phone? Move it forward.
Jake:  放哪了
Jake: Where did you put it?
Katrina:  你是要录我们刚刚跟音乐的吗
Katrina: Are you recording us with the music we just played?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Katrina:  还是从头
Katrina: Or from the beginning?
Jake: 额就是你们来跳一次比较完整的就行
Jake: Just do a complete run-through, that's fine.
Shure:  那我们给大家展示一下这个第一部分
Shure: Let's show everyone the first part.
Shure:  我们跳的最好的这一部分
Shure: The part we do the best.
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Alright.
Nicous: 好
Nicous: Okay.
Jake: 全景相机
Jake: Panoramic camera.
Jake: 就是相当于这边出一人看你们
Jake: Like someone over here watching you.
Shure:  OK准备好了吗
Shure: OK, are you ready?
Shure:  ready
Shure: Ready.
Nicous: 好
Nicous: Okay.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure:  二三四五六七八
Shure: Two three four five six seven eight.
Shure:  二二三四五六七八
Shure: Two two three four five six seven eight.
Shure:  三二三四五六七八四
Shure: Three two three four five six seven eight four.
Shure:  二三四跑二三起
Shure: Two three four run two three go.
Shure:  一二三四张二收
Shure: One two three four open two close.
Shure:  二三二三四摆
Shure: Two three two three four pose.
Shure:  二三划二二三四五六七八
Shure: Two three swipe two two three four five six seven eight.
Shure:  伸二比心张
Shure: Stretch two heart pose open.
Shure:  二三走一二
Shure: Two three walk one two.
Shure:  哈哈哈二三四五六七八
Shure: Hahaha two three four five six seven eight.
Shure:  一二三四五六七八
Shure: One two three four five six seven eight.
Shure:  踏步二一二三四
Shure: Step two one two three four.
Shure:  一二三四跑跳
Shure: One two three four run and jump.
Shure:  二三四张二收
Shure: Two, three, four, two, collect
Shure:  二三四划二三四摸手
Shure: Two, three, four, swipe, two, three, four, touch hands
Shure:  二三四顶二三四
Shure: Two, three, four, push, two, three, four
Shure:  二三四一二三停
Shure: Two, three, four, one, two, three, stop
Shure:  简单
Shure: Simple
Katrina:  第二部分要不要再过一遍
Katrina: Should we go over the second part again?
Shure:  来第二部分再跟他过一遍
Shure: Alright, let's go over the second part again.
Nicous: 直接0.75
Nicous: Just go 0.75
Choiszt: 好直接0.75
Choiszt: Okay, just go 0.75
Katrina:  真的吗
Katrina: Really?
Nicous: 我觉得我们可以直接第一第二连起来
Nicous: I think we can directly connect the first and second parts.
Shure:  嘿嘿哇
Shure: Haha, wow
Tasha: 你就这么自信的吗
Tasha: Are you that confident?
Jake: 这是
Jake: This is
Choiszt: 这三部分完整的
Choiszt: These three parts are complete.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh man
Nicous: 你以为就三部分
Nicous: You thought it was just three parts?
Choiszt: 我觉得可以
Choiszt: I think it's fine.
Lucia: 这三部分加起来
Lucia: These three parts combined
Lucia: 好像没有到完整的时长
Lucia: don't seem to reach the full length.
Nicous: 感觉还有可多可多空间
Nicous: Feels like there's still a lot of space.
Lucia: 那就从从头单曲循环
Lucia: Then let's loop it from the beginning.
Shure:  1234223412 船二张二开二一二三四
Shure: 1234223412, boat, two, stretch, two, one, two, three, four
Shure:  四 1234223412
Shure: Four, 1234223412
Shure:  three go一二三四五六七八
Shure: Three, go, one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight
Shure:  二二三四五六七八转胯
Shure: Two, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, turn hips
Shure:  三四五六拍拍一二三四五六七停
Shure: Three, four, five, six, clap, one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, stop
Lucia: 我觉得第二趴还是练一下吧
Lucia: I think we should still practice the second part.
Shure: sorrysorry
Shure: Sorry, sorry
Lucia: 因为手和脚上动作要合一下
Lucia: Because the hand and foot movements need to be coordinated.
Shure:  哇嚎
Shure: Wow, okay
Nicous:   原来这么没用啊
Nicous: So it turned out to be this useless.
Jake: 好下一个环节
Jake: Alright, next segment.
Lucia: 下一个什么环节
Lucia: What's the next segment?
Katrina:  什么环节
Katrina: What segment?
Jake: 你的花行吧
Jake: Your flower arrangement
Katrina: 哦哦哦
Katrina: Oh, oh, oh
Choiszt: 朝我杰作是吗
Choiszt: Stealing my masterpiece, right?
Choiszt: 行抄我杰作咋俩
Choiszt: Okay, stealing my masterpiece, us two.
Jake: 行好好好好行行
Jake: Alright, alright, alright, fine.
Shure:  哎行行行
Shure: Okay, okay, okay.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:都录着呢啊
Jake: It's all being recorded.
Katrina:  好行吧去选花吧
Katrina: Alright, let's go pick some flowers.
Shure:  他的出镜率不比他来出镜率低是吧
Shure: His screen time is not less than his, right?
Jake: 对我们第第七位选手
Jake: Yes, our seventh contestant.
Tasha: 几点啦
Tasha: What time is it?
Katrina:  哦4点了是不是也得准备菜啥的
Katrina: Oh, it's 4 o'clock. Should we start preparing the food and stuff?
Jake: 对是的
Jake: Yes, that's right.
Katrina: 啊 那您选一下花
Katrina: Ah, then you pick a flower.
Jake: 对领个花就是我们的活动
Jake: Yes, picking a flower is part of our event.
Jake: 我们可以再给你给跟个剧组讲解一下
Jake: We can explain it to the crew again.
Shure: 都走 你先走onetwo
Shure: Everyone, go ahead. You go first, one, two.
Katrina: 确实很容易出汗啊
Katrina: It's really easy to sweat.
Katrina:  你别说有的女团舞特别会
Katrina: You know, some girl group dances are really tough.
Katrina:  但是你知道那里有个嘿怕叫那个
Katrina: But you know, there's this one called "Hey Pa"...
Katrina:  itUIE
Katrina: itUIE
Katrina:  一击他们的舞
Katrina: Their dance moves...
Katrina:  跳下来就是半条命都没有
Katrina: After you finish, it's like you're half-dead.
Shure:  半条命都没了
Shure: Half-dead.
Shure:  我晓得在哪里
Shure: I know where that is.
Shure: yesok
Shure: Yes, okay.
Lucia: 但是理论上说
Lucia: But theoretically speaking...
Lucia: 最后跳怎样其实不是特别重要
Lucia: How we dance at the end isn't that important.
Lucia: 对吧我们只要有这个数据就行
Lucia: Right? As long as we have the data.
Katrina:  写一下名字簿然后贴跳一束花
Katrina: Write it in the name book and attach a flower.
Katrina:  然后每天要给他拍照
Katrina: Then take a photo of it every day.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yes.
Katrina:  因为有的花苞这就是他会慢慢盛开
Katrina: Because some flower buds will slowly bloom.
Nicous: 这是什么人能想出来的东西这个充电器
Nicous: Who could come up with this charger thing?
Katrina:  写名字写名字
Katrina: Write the name, write the name.
Nicous: 写哪个
Nicous: Which one?
Shure: 写名字
Shure: Write the name.
Jake: 写名字写
Jake: Write the name, write it.
Nicous: 这儿哦
Nicous: Here, oh.
Katrina: 这儿我挑了
Katrina: Here, I picked it.
Shure:  谁让你挑的
Shure: Who let you pick it?
Katrina:  偷偷挑的
Katrina: I secretly picked it.
Katrina:  挑的最好的
Katrina: Picked the best one.
Shure:  那怎么就是你呢
Shure: Why is it you then?
Katrina:  今晚上还可以再练好
Katrina: We can practice more tonight.
Shure:  我要这个了
Shure: I want this one.
Jake: 有你俩事
Jake: Is this your business?
Jake: 你俩再倒个数
Jake: You two count down again.
Choiszt: ok
Choiszt: Ok.
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on.
Katrina:  我的草莓
Katrina: My strawberry.
Jake:抱对啊
Jake: Hug it right.
Tasha: 名花有主了啊
Tasha: It's taken already.
Tasha: 那个也有
Tasha: That one too.
Lucia: 那我就这个好了
Lucia: Then I'll take this one.
Lucia: 反正他是离我最近的
Lucia: After all, it's the closest to me.
Katrina:  就是要泡几分钟
Katrina: It just needs to soak for a few minutes.
Tasha: 这个好像没有
Tasha: This one doesn't seem to have it.
Tasha: 芍药有一个
Tasha: The peony has one.
Lucia: 他应该是还没开就是
Lucia: It probably hasn't bloomed yet.
Tasha: 应该各种都放了芍药的球球
Tasha: I think they planted peony bulbs everywhere.
Katrina:  等他慢慢开就好了
Katrina: Just wait for it to bloom slowly.
Katrina:  对这些都是芍药球
Katrina: Yes, these are all peony bulbs.
Choiszt: 少把椅子再搬把椅子
Choiszt: Move the chair again, bring a chair.
Katrina:  芍药开出来好大呀
Katrina: Peonies bloom very big.
Katrina:  哎笔上哪去了
Katrina: Hey, where did the pen go?
Katrina:  自己房间装饰购买
Katrina: Decorate your own room.
Shure:  我房间有地放花
Shure: I have space for flowers in my room.
Choiszt: 来来来过一下
Choiszt: Come, come, let's go over it.
Shure:  应该有吧
Shure: There should be, right?
Lucia: 可以把它融入到我们的房间装饰里
Lucia: We can incorporate it into our room decor.
Katrina:  你也可以把它放在这客厅某一个位置
Katrina: You can also place it somewhere in the living room.
Katrina:  都行反正你自己管着它
Katrina: It doesn't matter, you take care of it.
Katrina:  每天要拍照
Katrina: You need to take photos every day.
Shure:  每天要拍照
Shure: Take photos every day.
Katrina:  哎呀老学我的口音干什么
Katrina: Ah, why are you mimicking my accent?
Katrina:  哈哈哈可以放外面剥
Katrina: Haha, you can peel it outside.
Katrina:  它需要那个光合作用吗
Katrina: It needs photosynthesis, right?
Shure:  外面不好剥
Shure: It's hard to peel outside.
Katrina:  就是生物钟
Katrina: It's like a biological clock.
Katrina:  它们是需要进行光合作用好像
Katrina: They need to perform photosynthesis, I think.
Katrina:  但是也不能长时间进行光合作用
Katrina: But they can't do photosynthesis for too long.
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed.
Katrina:  你还记得吗
Katrina: Do you remember?
Katrina:  好像会那个什么死掉
Katrina: It might just die or something.
Katrina:  就是那个系统
Katrina: It's the system.
Choiszt: 蒸腾作用
Choiszt: Transpiration.
Katrina:  对对蒸腾
Katrina: Yes, yes, transpiration.
Shure:  你看看
Shure: Look at that.
Shure:  这脑子
Shure: This brain.
Katrina:  就是有文化哎
Katrina: So knowledgeable.
Alice: 嗯这怎么断了一根
Alice: Hmm, how did this one break?
Katrina:  断了么
Katrina: Did it break?
Nicous: 帮我哪个那个胶
Nicous: Pass me that glue.
Shure:  Daison i need a corporation
Shure: Daison, I need a corporation.
Katrina:  酸奶酸奶
Katrina: Yogurt, yogurt.
Shure: 放哪了呢
Shure: Where did you put it?
Shure:  我那边是阴面
Shure: My side is shady.
Shure:  不一样花
Shure: Different flowers.
Lucia: 我觉得我房间要是放阳台上
Lucia: If I put my room on the balcony...
Jake: 呃等一下
Jake: Uh, hold on.
Jake: 找不着了
Jake: Can't find it.
Jake: 挑完了吗
Jake: Are you done picking?
Jake: 大伙
Jake: Everyone.
Lucia: 哎呦sorry
Lucia: Oh sorry.
Choiszt: 没事没事
Choiszt: It's okay, it's okay.
Tasha: 你贴了吗
Tasha: Did you stick it?
Tasha: 这个是你的吗
Tasha: Is this yours?
Lucia: 今天的照片
Lucia: Today's photo.
Lucia: 我把它放哪拍了
Lucia: Where did I take it?
Katrina:  看看芍药需要几天才能开花
Katrina: See how many days it takes for the peony to bloom.
Lucia: 这里
Lucia: Here.
Jake: 幸亏他妈的买个可乐是吧
Jake: Luckily, we bought a Coke, right?
Katrina:  有一点点背光
Katrina: It's a bit backlit.
Jake: 哎呀挑好了吗
Jake: Hey, are you done picking?
Katrina:  挑好了
Katrina: Yes, I am.
Katrina:  给我留的哪个呀
Katrina: Which one did you leave for me?
Tasha: 那要不拿昨天那个
Tasha: How about taking the one from yesterday?
Tasha: 昨天那个在哪
Tasha: Where is the one from yesterday?
Jake: 这个这个嗯
Jake: This one, this one, hmm.
Jake: 这什么花呀
Jake: What flower is this?
Katrina:  这这是芍药
Katrina: This is a peony.
Katrina:  这应该也是芍药
Katrina: This should also be a peony.
Katrina:  这是康乃馨
Katrina: This is a carnation.
Katrina:  然后这是百合
Katrina: And this is a lily.
Katrina:  哎剪子在哪里
Katrina: Hey, where are the scissors?
Tasha: 在这呢
Tasha: They're here.
Katrina: 剪花的那个
Katrina: The ones for cutting flowers.
Katrina:  好来剪一下
Katrina: Alright, let's cut it.
Shure:  我们给自己的花起个名吧
Shure: Let's name our flowers.
Katrina:  桑葚
Katrina: Mulberry.
Shure:   OK
Shure: OK.
Katrina:  你可以叫Sunshine或者叫smile
Katrina: You can call it Sunshine or Smile.
Shure:  smile才可爱型
Shure: Smile sounds cuter.
Jake: 这个不能乱关
Jake: You can't just turn this off.
Jake: 这关了硬盘就会坏
Jake: Turning this off will damage the hard drive.
Jake: 来一个硬盘
Jake: Get me a hard drive.
Jake: 然后搞成这个样子
Jake: And make it look like this.
Jake: 血汗工厂开店
Jake: Sweatshop opened.
Choiszt: 这个也要
Choiszt: This one too.
Nicous: 我曹
Nicous: Damn.
Jake: 你你们进去吧
Jake: You guys go in.
Jake: 这这两个给你们
Jake: These two are for you.
Katrina:  好像都是自习室啊
Katrina: They all look like study rooms.
Katrina:  就是那个
Katrina: Just like that.
Katrina:  减负不准办补习班
Katrina: No cram schools allowed for reducing the burden.
Tasha: 不可能不查啊
Tasha: They can't possibly not check.
Jake: 禁止办公
Jake: No office work allowed.
Jake: 这边贴一个禁止办公
Jake: Put a 'No Office Work' sign here.
Lucia: 这个标语我喜欢
Lucia: I like this sign.
Katrina:  排排坐下
Katrina: Sit in a row.
Shure:  你们仨是网吧三连坐是吧
Shure: You three are like in an internet cafe.
Lucia: 真的像
Lucia: It really looks like it.
Lucia: 这外面这桌子是不是有点有点歪这
Lucia: Is this table a bit crooked?
Lucia: 个板哪个不是
Lucia: Which board isn't?
Lucia: 就是这板好像不太平
Lucia: This board seems uneven.
Jake: 对对对是的是的
Jake: Yeah, yeah, it is.
Jake: 他就是不够
Jake: It's just not enough.
Jake: 哈哈哈很勉强
Jake: Haha, it's really makeshift.
Tasha: 昂ok
Tasha: Right, OK.
Jake: 不过也行这样就好
Jake: But it's fine, this will do.
Shure: 我天哪
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure:  你们仨准备打点什么英雄联盟吧
Shure: Are you three planning to play some League of Legends?
Jake: 三个人能打什么呀
Jake: What can three people play?
Jake: 帮我拿一下啊
Jake: Help me grab that.
Jake: 斗地主
Jake: Playing Dou Di Zhu.
Jake: 帮我拿一下
Jake: Help me grab it.
Jake: 三个人三人可以APEX
Jake: Three people can play APEX.
Lucia: 三人可以联机玩刺客信条黑棋
Lucia: Three people can play Assassin's Creed Black Flag online.
Shure:  可以永结无间
Shure: Can play Naraka too.
Shure:  这首赶紧给我们的
Shure: Let's quickly give our...
Shure: 网易打波广告
Shure: NetEase a little ad.
Shure:  这样这是干嘛的呀
Shure: So, what is this for?
Katrina:  做引体向上
Katrina: For doing pull-ups.
Shure: 挂个杆然后做引体向上是吧
Shure: Hang a bar and do pull-ups, right?
Shure: 能能撑住吗
Shure: Can it hold up?
Lucia: 我们乱说的
Lucia: We were just joking.
Lucia: 小心一点
Lucia: Be careful.
Jake: 挺好挺好
Jake: It's good, it's good.
Shure:  主要我撑不起来
Shure: Mainly, I can't pull myself up.
Shure:  需要给他修剪吗
Shure: Do we need to trim it?
Katrina:  随便你你的话
Katrina: It's up to you.
Katrina:  你想修的话可以修呀
Katrina: If you want to trim it, you can.
Shure:  我不修因为我姓修了已经
Shure: I won't trim it because my surname is already "Shure."
Shure:  就你就卡到这就行了
Shure: You can just leave it like this.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Jake: 看这个就是我的床的入口
Jake: Look, this is the entrance to my bed.
Choiszt: OK
Choiszt: OK.
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Whoa.
Jake: 全自动入口
Jake: Fully automatic entrance.
Shure: 你能过来吗
Shure: Can you fit through?
Shure:  这么大地
Shure: It's so big.
Jake: 能啊这个一跳不就上上床
Jake: Of course, just jump and you're on the bed.
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Whoa.
Lucia: sorry一跳就上床了感觉
Lucia: Sorry, just jump and you're on the bed.
Jake:入口
Jake: Entrance.
Katrina:  嗯理想中的房间
Katrina: Yeah, an ideal room.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Jake: 饶了我吧
Jake: Spare me.
Katrina: 这个确实是软件工程理想中的房间
Katrina: This is indeed the ideal room for a software engineer.
Lucia: 写完代码直接倒头就睡
Lucia: Finish coding and then just fall asleep.
Jake: 刚拿过来的这个
Jake: Just brought this over.
Jake: 对放拿过去
Jake: Yes, put it over there.
Katrina:  一楼这投影仪也可以
Katrina: This projector on the first floor is nice too.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Katrina:  放点music可以吗
Katrina: Can we play some music?
Shure:  来点music
Shure: Let's have some music.
Jake: 来点music
Jake: Let's have some music.
Katrina: yes
Katrina: Yes.
Katrina:  反正戴了眼镜了
Katrina: Since I'm wearing glasses anyway.
Katrina:  已经录下你们
Katrina: I've already recorded you guys.
Jake: 你们要现在是要干啥呀
Jake: So, what are you guys planning to do now?
Katrina:  我们可以讨论一下
Katrina: We can discuss...
Katrina:  我们的那个房间装饰
Katrina: Our room decoration.
Katrina:  你不是说要录对录下来吗
Katrina: Didn't you say you wanted to record it?
Jake: 对然后这个他们应该
Jake: Yes, and they should...
Jake: 他说是四五点会有人过来收拾
Jake: He said someone would come around four or five to clean up.
Jake:  对然后那会收拾
Jake: Yes, and then they will clean up.
Jake: 收拾完我们就扫房间就
Jake: After they clean up, we'll sweep the room.
Jake: 是扫3D扫
Jake: Sweep it in 3D.
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Hmm, yes.
Jake: 好 4399
Jake: Okay, 4399.
Jake: 哈哈哈那提前准备食材
Jake: Haha, then prepare the ingredients in advance.
Shure:  死神vs辉啊这不得来吗
Shure: Death vs. Light, we have to do it, right?
Jake: 要不现在就开始准备食材吧然后
Jake: How about we start preparing the ingredients now?
Lucia: 都可以
Lucia: Anything's fine.
Jake: 对现在开始准备食材
Jake: Yes, start preparing the ingredients now.
Jake: 就现在就看一看准备准备
Jake: Let's take a look and get ready.
Katrina:  现在也可以看
Katrina: We can look now too.
Katrina:  那个房间装饰购买
Katrina: At room decoration purchases.
Jake: 也可以
Jake: Sure.
Katrina:  然后5点他来收拾然后扫房间
Katrina: Then at five, he will come to clean and sweep the room.
Katrina:  我们只需要稍微收拾一下
Katrina: We just need to tidy up a bit.
Katrina:  我们就下来忙这个呗
Katrina: Then we can start working on this.
Jake:可以
Jake: That works.
Katrina:  扫房间是你们三个弄是吧
Katrina: You three are sweeping the room, right?
Jake: 呃就打扫房间是不是
Jake: Uh, you mean cleaning the room, right?
Jake: 嗯不用不用我们都不用弄
Jake: Hmm, no, we don't need to do it.
Katrina:  OK那我们那个吧
Katrina: OK, then we can...
Tasha: 那你先放一下我看我要买什么
Tasha: You go ahead and I'll see what I need to buy.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Katrina:  我想买那个
Katrina: I want to buy that.
Choiszt: 关掉4399
Choiszt: Turn off 4399.
Katrina:  我想搞成森林主义
Katrina: I want to go for a forest theme.
Jake: 然后那个
Jake: And then that...
Katrina: 我要全绿色
Katrina: I want all green.
Lucia: 上海我想好我要怎么样
Lucia: In Shanghai, I've decided what I want to do.
Lucia: 我想我想借一个同学的作业抄一下
Lucia: I think I want to borrow a classmate's homework to copy.
Tasha: 我本来想弄蓝的
Tasha: I originally wanted blue.
Tasha: 后来发现蓝的太难买了
Tasha: But then I found out blue is too hard to find.
Tasha: 然后昨天晚上也挑了绿的
Tasha: So I picked green last night too.
Katrina:  也可以搞那种极简的
Katrina: You could also go for that minimalist style.
Katrina:  那种无印良品风也行
Katrina: The Muji style is also good.
Choiszt:  都都可以
Choiszt: Both are fine.
Tasha: 我的衣服里面找到一堆绿的呢
Tasha: I found a bunch of green clothes in my wardrobe.
Tasha: 我喜欢
Tasha: I like it.
Katrina:  你房间有那个钩子吗
Katrina: Do you have hooks in your room?
Katrina:  没有就是我房间有两个钩子
Katrina: No? Well, I have two hooks in my room.
Katrina:  我感觉可以买那种挂画海报呢
Katrina: I feel like we can get those hanging posters.
Shure:  这样吧我们建一个歌单
Shure: How about this, let's make a playlist.
Shure:  然后大家一人报一个歌名
Shure: Everyone suggest a song.
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Okay?
Katrina:  就是就是大家可以想听什么自己输进去
Katrina: So, everyone can just input the songs they want to listen to.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 然后我们搞随机播放
Katrina: And then we can do random play.
Shure: 好
Shure: Alright.
Katrina:   有点像那个随机舞蹈了哈哈
Katrina: It's kind of like a random dance, haha.
Shure:  来大家先一人说一个歌名
Shure: Everyone name a song first.
Shure:  我先都不放
Shure: I won't play anything yet.
Shure:  然后都加到歌单里
Shure: Then we'll add them to the playlist.
Shure:  然后这个歌单随便放
Shure: And then we'll play the playlist randomly.
Shure:  可以吧
Shure: Sound good?
Katrina: 想听的歌
Lucia: 我打开我的apple music
Lucia: I'll open my Apple Music.
Lucia: 然后突然发现
Lucia: And suddenly I realized...
Lucia: 我的我的APP账号在登在里面
Lucia: My app account is logged in there.
Lucia: 所以找不到自己听的歌单
Lucia: So I can't find my playlist.
Lucia: 我得重新登录一下
Lucia: I need to log in again.
Shure:  你要什么
Shure: What do you want?
Shure: 爱很简单
Shure: "Love is Simple."
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Jake: 你看看这里面是什么东西
Jake: Check what's inside here.
Lucia: 哇这首歌每次都是演唱会的压轴
Lucia: Wow, this song is always the finale at concerts.
Shure: 陶喆
Shure: David Tao.
Jake: 十一号没人换是吧
Jake: No one is switching on the 11th, right?
Shure: 哦好像
Shure: Oh, it seems like
Shure: 不是没有陶喆版本的
Shure: There's no David Tao version
Jake: 万一要是原来送一个二五
Jake: What if we send a 25 instead
Lucia: 有没有VIP是吧
Lucia: Are there any VIPs?
Shure:  啊这个带着逗号OKOK
Shure: Ah, this one has a comma, OK OK
Shure:  好先不慌
Shure: Alright, don't panic for now
Shure:  先加入歌单
Shure: First, add it to the playlist
Shure:   收藏已购
Shure: Save it to favorites
Lucia: 等会等会
Lucia: Wait a minute
Lucia: 这样拍张照好好
Lucia: Let's take a picture like this
Lucia: 有那种综艺的感觉
Lucia: It feels like a variety show
Shure: 是的 还有什么
Shure: Yeah, what else?
Lucia: 我我我点那个打雷姐的video Games
Lucia: I, I, I want to play that "Video Games" by Lana Del Rey
Shure:  VIDDividiovdo该慕斯这又什么
Shure: VIDDividiovdo, what's this again?
Katrina: 海报我一直没挑好
Katrina: I still haven't picked the poster
Katrina:  不知道挑好看兰纳德雷的对
Katrina: Don't know which one looks good, Lana Del Rey's, right?
Shure: OK
Jake: 一样的应该每个电脑都得有
Jake: It should be the same, every computer should have it
Shure: 还有什么
Shure: What else?
Katrina: 还有什么
Katrina: What else?
Alice:蝴蝶
Alice: Butterfly
Shure: 蝴蝶谁的
Shure: Whose "Butterfly"?
Alice: 陶吉吉
Alice: David Tao
Lucia: 你也喜欢这首歌吗
Lucia: You like this song too?
Lucia: 我挺喜欢
Lucia: I quite like it
Lucia: 这是我超喜欢的一首歌
Lucia: It's one of my favorite songs
Shure:  还有什么
Shure: What else?
Tasha: 但是分手是狂人
Tasha: But breaking up is crazy
Tasha: 上去收拾东西
Tasha: Go upstairs and pack your things
Jake: 毫无抵抗力
Jake: No resistance at all
Lucia: 他还没有报警
Lucia: He hasn't called the police yet
Lucia: 报歌
Lucia: Reporting the song
Katrina:  我可以多搞搞那个
Katrina: I can work more on that
Katrina:  我最近喜欢听那个张璇的
Katrina: I've been liking that Zhang Xuan's song lately
Shure:  我的宝贝
Shure: My baby
Shure:  宝贝
Shure: Baby
Katrina: 和他那个烟火
Katrina: And his "Fireworks"
Shure:  加这首
Shure: Add this song
Jake: 对
Jake: Right
Katrina:  也可以放
Katrina: You can put it there.
Katrina:  你你你会跳舞吗
Katrina: Can you dance?
Shure:  好好哈哈哈
Shure: Haha, okay.
Shure:  最出圈的是吧
Shure: The most viral one, right?
Shure:  今天晚上就洗
Shure: We'll wash it tonight.
Jake: 那个应该是被我亲掉的卡布
Jake: That should be the cappuccino I kissed off.
Jake: 也也行吧
Jake: Yeah, that's fine.
Shure:  但是很蠢
Shure: But it's really dumb.
Shure:  你刚才说的是什么
Shure: What did you just say?
Jake: 就是这就不统一
Jake: It's just not consistent.
Katrina:  我点一个音乐剧里面的
Katrina: I'll pick one from a musical.
Shure:  好
Shure: Sure.
Jake: 要吧我感觉我记忆有点
Jake: Do you want it? I feel like my memory is a bit...
Katrina:  就是7秒钟
Katrina: Just 7 seconds.
Katrina:  刚说
Katrina: Just said.
Shure: 嗨嗨米欧是这么拼的吧
Shure: Hi, is that how you spell "Mio"?
Katrina: 对的对的
Katrina: Yes, that's correct.
Shure: 这个是吧
Shure: This one, right?
Katrina:  对就开场焰火
Katrina: Yes, the opening fireworks.
Shure:  焰火是吧还有人要点歌吗
Shure: Fireworks, right? Anyone else want to request a song?
Lucia: 有人要点
Lucia: Anyone wants to request a song?
Lucia: 歌吗你们三位要点歌吗
Lucia: Do you three want to request a song?
Jake: 那不修硕的事情吗
Jake: Isn't that Shure's job?
Lucia: 点歌点歌
Lucia: Request a song.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No.
Shure: 陈翔的吗还是郭采洁的
Shure: Chen Xiang's or Amber Kuo's?
Choiszt:  就这样吧
Choiszt: Let's go with that.
Katrina: 不是艳艳丽的艳艳火张安普
Katrina: Not "Yan Yan Li" but "Yan Yan Fire" by Zhang Anpu.
Shure: 艳丽啊安普啊呜
Shure: Yan Yan, Anpu, ah.
Katrina:  最近很喜欢他
Katrina: I really like him recently.
Katrina:  就是晚上一个人把那个
Katrina: Just one person at night with that.
Katrina:  但是这房间隔音不太好
Katrina: But this room isn't well soundproofed.
Katrina:  估计大家也听到
Katrina: Probably everyone can hear.
Shure: 没事
Shure: It's fine.
Jake: 呃首先这个东西它在
Jake: Uh, first of all, this thing, it is...
Jake: 它是
Jake: It is...
Shure:  安抚还是安普这个字念
Shure: Anfu or Anpu, how do you pronounce it?
Katrina: 我看是安普啊
Katrina: I think it's Anpu.
Jake: 哎这为什么在我手上
Jake: Hey, why is this in my hand?
Jake: 嗯这个为什么在我手上
Jake: Hmm, why is this in my hand?
Katrina:  呀涉及到这是什么
Katrina: Ah, what is this about?
Jake: 这是十一号吗
Jake: Is this number eleven?
Shure: 不会拼打这个字
Shure: I can't spell this word.
Katrina:  安
Katrina: "An"
Jake: 你别弄乱了
Jake: Don't mess it up.
Jake: 弄弄乱傻逼了
Jake: Messing it up is stupid.
Jake: 这个这这个给我
Jake: This, this, give it to me.
Shure: 是普
Shure: It's "Pu."
Katrina:  这是念谱吧
Katrina: This should be pronounced "Pu," right?
Shure: 艳火是吧
Shure: "Yanhuo," right?
Shure: 点一首
Shure: Play a song.
Shure: 这前两天刚回归网易云
Shure: Just got back on NetEase Cloud two days ago.
Lucia: 那我点那个滚石的
Lucia: Then I'll pick a Rolling Stones song.
Lucia: 不是滚石
Lucia: Not Rolling Stones.
Lucia: 枪花的碎片珠
Lucia: Guns N' Roses' "Shattered Beads."
Jake: 我手上是什么
Jake: What's in my hand?
Shure:  哎呦
Shure: Oh!
Lucia: 超喜欢这个突然想起来
Lucia: I really like this one, just remembered.
Jake: 行这样吧
Jake: Okay, let's do this.
Shure: 这才是老摇滚
Shure: This is real old-school rock.
Jake: 就是你这二楼的戏品主搞一楼的
Jake: You second floor guys manage the first floor stuff.
Shure: 好
Shure: Alright.
Lucia: 经常在听老歌
Lucia: I often listen to old songs.
Jake: 就是首先你下一个
Jake: So, you're next.
Katrina: 好有意思大家听的完全不一样
Katrina: It's interesting, everyone listens to totally different things.
Jake: 下一个VLC VLC VLC
Jake: Next is VLC, VLC, VLC.
Shure: 再来一首什么
Shure: What should we play next?
Shure:  谁刚刚没有点歌来着
Shure: Who didn't pick a song earlier?
Lucia: VC点歌吗
Lucia: Did VC pick a song?
Katrina:  他点了蝴蝶
Katrina: He picked "Butterfly."
Shure: 蝴蝶点过了
Shure: "Butterfly" was already picked.
Katrina:  蝴蝶点过
Katrina: "Butterfly" was picked.
Lucia: 对你还你还你
Lucia: Yeah, you, you, you...
Lucia: 还没点应该
Lucia: Haven't picked yet, right?
Shure: 还有谁没点
Shure: Who else hasn't picked?
Katrina:  有啥想听的歌不
Katrina: Is there any song you want to hear?
Tasha: 一人要点一首是吗
Tasha: Everyone has to pick one song, right?
Choiszt: 这边要点陈奕迅的
Choiszt: Over here, we want to pick an Eason Chan song.
Katrina: 对对对
Katrina: Yeah, yeah.
Nicous: 来首陈奕迅的
Nicous: Let's play an Eason Chan song.
Katrina:  来首陈奕迅
Katrina: Let's play a song by Eason Chan.
Lucia:  点哪个浮夸
Lucia: Which one, "Exaggerated"?
Choiszt:  呵呵来一首周杰伦
Choiszt: Haha, how about a Jay Chou song?
Tasha: 我手机呢
Tasha: Where's my phone?
Shure:  周杰伦没有我是
Shure: No Jay Chou, only me.
Lucia: 陈奕迅还是周杰伦
Lucia: Eason Chan or Jay Chou?
Tasha: 嗯我想听那个爱是一本书
Tasha: Hmm, I want to listen to "Love is a Book".
Tasha: 就是陈奕迅的爱是一本书
Tasha: The one by Eason Chan, "Love is a Book".
Shure:  爱是一本书OK
Shure: "Love is a Book", okay.
Jake: 哎你这怎么
Jake: Hey, what are you doing?
Shure: 这个是吧OK
Shure: This one, right? Okay.
Tasha: 我也来帮陈奕迅点一个浮夸
Tasha: I'll also request "Exaggerated" by Eason Chan.
Shure: 好
Shure: Alright.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 卧槽你是几天没睡觉你
Jake: Damn, how many days haven't you slept?
修硕;ok
Shure: Okay.
Jake: hello啊你你你抿一下
Jake: Hello, can you, can you sip that?
Shure: 葡萄成熟时
Shure: "When the Grapes Ripen".
Jake: 你要干嘛
Jake: What are you trying to do?
Jake: OK你现在电脑里边
Jake: Okay, now on your computer...
Katrina: 这是什么软件
Katrina: What's this software?
Jake: 你你现在电脑里边是什么
Jake: What's on your computer now?
Jake: 7号
Jake: Number 7.
Choiszt:  我现在是7号
Choiszt: I'm on number 7 now.
Jake: 7号 拔出来先
Jake: Number 7, pull it out first.
Jake: 不要7号
Jake: Don't use number 7.
Katrina:  确实对我觉得网易云唯一不足
Katrina: Yeah, I think NetEase Cloud's only flaw...
Katrina:  就是没有周杰伦
Katrina: is that it doesn't have Jay Chou.
Katrina:  就是你得切另一个软件
Katrina: You have to switch to another app.
Lucia:  哦是
Lucia: Oh, right.
Lucia: 网易云上压根就没
Lucia: NetEase Cloud doesn't have it at all.
Shure: 没有那个版权
Shure: They don't have the rights.
Lucia:  OK
Lucia: OK.
Shure:  来吧随机播放
Shure: Let's go, shuffle play.
Shure:  第一首先放大是吧
Shure: First, let's enlarge this, right?
Shure:  就先放你这个吧好吧
Shure: Let's play yours first, okay?
Katrina:  嗯然后你按随机
Katrina: Hmm, then press shuffle.
Katrina:  看你这音效效果怎么样
Katrina: Let's see how the sound quality is.
Nicous:  OK
Nicous: Okay.
Shure: 他怎么没声呢
Shure: Why isn't there any sound?
Lucia: 电话吗这是
Lucia: Is this a phone call?
Jake: 稍微拿一下
Jake: Hold on a moment.
Katrina: 安康
Katrina: Ankang
Jake: 从你从9号开始
Jake: Start from the 9th.
Shure:  是的这我原来乐队的名字
Shure: Yes, that was my old band's name.
Jake: 呃九号
Jake: Uh, the 9th.
Katrina: 我们学校乐队叫哈喽我的
Katrina: Our school band is called Hello My
Jake: 对十一号跳过去
Jake: Yes, skip to the 11th.
Choiszt:  这个新买的是红色卡是256
Choiszt: The new one I bought is a red card, it's 256.
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Jake: 然后你们要做的事情是把每一层
Jake: And what you need to do is to make each floor
Jake: 就是按楼层
Jake: according to the floors.
Jake: 这个是一楼
Jake: This is the first floor.
Katrina:  哇对位耶
Katrina: Wow, it matches!
Jake: 这是一楼
Jake: This is the first floor.
Jake: 这是二楼
Jake: This is the second floor.
Lucia: 爽了
Lucia: Awesome!
Jake: 还能是谁哈哈
Jake: Who else could it be, haha.
Jake: 对啊
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 哎呀怎么把我网名念出来了
Lucia: Oh no, why did you say my screen name?
Jake: 陶喆
Jake: David Tao
Jake: 哈哈哈为什么还在3月2号
Jake: Haha, why is it still March 2nd?
Lucia: 因为不愿意
Lucia: Because I don't want to.
Lucia: 太激动了不想改
Lucia: Too excited to change it.
Jake: 对等到明年3月2号
Jake: Yeah, wait until next March 2nd.
Lucia: 等到什么时候
Lucia: Until when?
Lucia: 再看下一场了再改哦
Lucia: Then watch the next show and change it.
Lucia: 好好好对
Lucia: Okay, okay, right.
Lucia: 我看第一场在武汉
Lucia: I saw the first show in Wuhan.
Lucia: 我抢到了前驱票
Lucia: I got the advance tickets.
Lucia: 3月2号哦
Lucia: March 2nd.
Lucia: 那时候刚来学校一会
Lucia: Just started school back then.
Lucia: sorry哈哈哈
Lucia: Sorry, haha.
Lucia: 但是但是
Lucia: But, but
Lucia: 他现在嗓子已经回春很多了
Lucia: His voice has recovered a lot now.
Lucia: 他把那心乱肺的高音给飙上去了
Lucia: He hit those high notes beautifully.
Jake: 那就整整火锅呗
Jake: Then let's have some hotpot.
Jake: 然后聊一聊你们
Jake: And talk about you guys.
Lucia: OK我要买一下我的东西
Lucia: OK, I need to buy my stuff.
Jake: 让数据丰富起来
Jake: Let's make the data richer.
Katrina:  今天可丰富了
Katrina: Today is so eventful.
Katrina:  今天那么多知识动作
Katrina: So much to learn today.
Jake: 现在也要丰富起来
Jake: We need to make it even more eventful now.
Alice: 我给你剪
Alice: I'll cut it for you.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm.
Katrina:  哎我靠这好看
Katrina: Wow, this looks so good.
Lucia: 我到现在还没想好买啥
Lucia: I still haven't decided what to buy.
Katrina:  其实现在好多那种
Katrina: Actually, there are so many of those...
Katrina:  就是那种很有意思的做的家具
Katrina: You know, those interesting furniture pieces.
Katrina:  我选一个整屋定制
Katrina: I chose a custom whole-room setup.
Lucia: 好好看哈哈哈
Lucia: It looks great, haha.
Katrina:  整屋定制
Katrina: Custom whole-room setup.
Jake: 你要外包是吧
Jake: You want to outsource it, right?
Shure:  外包哈哈哈
Shure: Outsourcing, haha.
Jake: 500块钱200外包
Jake: 500 bucks, 200 for outsourcing.
Jake: 哈哈层层外包
Jake: Haha, layer upon layer of outsourcing.
Jake: 不是不是VLC啊
Jake: No, not VLC.
Jake: 不像是VLC
Jake: It doesn't seem like VLC.
Lucia: 因为这种对于我这个很多恐惧症来说
Lucia: Because for someone with many phobias like me...
Lucia: 真的很难搞啊
Lucia: It's really difficult.
Katrina:  我还有一个小阳台
Katrina: I also have a small balcony.
Katrina:  我阳台上学VLC
Katrina: I study VLC on my balcony.
Jake: 这个是的
Jake: Yeah, that's right.
Jake: 你瞎盗版了
Jake: You're pirating it.
Jake: 哈哈哈学学
Jake: Haha, learning pirated stuff.
Jake: 挺准的你
Jake: You're quite accurate.
Shure: 哎呦sorry
Shure: Oh, sorry.
Jake: 因为
Jake: Because...
Jake: 因为你这个硬盘也要放在这个地方
Jake: Because you need to place this hard drive here.
Jake: 然后但是这个硬盘你你不能摔着
Jake: But you can't drop this hard drive.
Jake: 然后插上
Jake: Then plug it in.
Katrina:  有一种岁月静好的感觉
Katrina: It feels so peaceful.
Shure: 嗯是的
Shure: Yes, it does.
Katrina: 他们在工作
Katrina: They are working.
Katrina:  然后这边在放歌这边在剪花
Katrina: And over here they're playing music and trimming flowers.
Shure:  我给你们加油打气
Shure: I'll cheer you on.
Shure:  我给你们跳
Shure: I'll dance for you.
Shure:  yes OK
Shure: Yes, OK.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哎我觉得他动作已经很多精髓了
Lucia: Hey, I think he's really got the essence of it.
Jake: 你要不把碗洗了
Jake: Why don't you wash the dishes?
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  哦落上面了那个
Shure: Oh, it's on the top there.
Jake: 等一下贴硬盘上要二
Jake: Wait a second, we need two for the hard drive.
Katrina:  天呐好多好看的都是要做手工的
Katrina: Oh my gosh, a lot of the pretty ones need to be handmade.
Katrina:  啊啊直接到浮夸了
Katrina: Ah, it’s getting too fancy.
Jake: 教外国人用淘宝也挺好
Jake: Teaching foreigners to use Taobao is also good.
Jake: 让他们羡慕去吧
Jake: Let them be envious.
Shure: 淘宝
Shure: Taobao.
Lucia: 有哪个购物平台给咱给赞助吗
Lucia: Is there any shopping platform sponsoring us?
Lucia: 就多用用他们的
Lucia: Then let's use theirs more often.
Jake: 这还有个帽子的还带着呢
Jake: There's still a hat here, isn't there?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哦
Lucia: Hahaha, oh.
Lucia: 亚马逊是吗
Lucia: Is it Amazon?
Lucia: 他们已经会用了
Lucia: They already know how to use it.
Lucia: 不用教哈哈
Lucia: No need to teach, haha.
Jake: 所以对对对对对
Jake: So, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Jake: 专门专门做Pro的第二层
Jake: Specially, specially made for Pro's second layer.
Jake: 然后你按照每一个相机
Jake: Then you follow each camera.
Jake: 嗯然后每一天
Jake: And then each day.
Shure: 从大雨落噶啊
Shure: From the heavy rain, ah.
Jake: 然后这个先上
Jake: Then put this on first.
Jake: 先上这个盘对吧
Jake: Put this disk first, right?
Jake: 你要要洗手是吗
Jake: Do you need to wash your hands?
Alice: 洗过
Alice: I already did.
Shure: 哦好
Shure: Oh, okay.
Shure: 这锅是呵呵
Shure: This pot is, haha.
Alice:这是啥
Alice: What is this?
Shure: 没事百洁布
Shure: It's nothing, just a scouring pad.
Nicous:  哈哈什么都没干
Nicous: Haha, did nothing at all.
Lucia: 你做作业
Lucia: You do your homework.
Lucia: 哈哈哈放心的
Lucia: Hahaha, no worries.
Lucia: 录好几次好几次
Lucia: Recorded several times, several times.
Tasha: 什么东西啊
Tasha: What's this?
Lucia: 这也好看
Lucia: This looks good too.
Lucia: 这面看特别有层次感
Lucia: This side looks particularly layered.
Jake: 是修剪了一遍
Jake: It's been trimmed once.
Jake: 修剪了狠狠的
Jake: Trimmed really well.
Jake: 修剪了一遍
Jake: Trimmed once.
Tasha: 也没有很狠
Tasha: It's not that harsh.
Tasha: 一般般
Tasha: So-so.
Jake: 确实好看了
Jake: It does look nice.
Tasha: 我好奇一下大家都写的什么符号
Tasha: I'm curious, what symbols did everyone draw?
Tasha: 我给他画的小翅膀
Tasha: I drew little wings for him.
Tasha: 但是画的有点丑
Tasha: But they turned out a bit ugly.
Jake: 我还没写
Jake: I haven't written mine yet.
Tasha: 我是个星
Tasha: I'm a star.
Lucia: 我是个小太阳
Lucia: I'm a little sun.
Lucia: 啊雨轩是直接写的名字嗯
Lucia: Ah, Yuxuan just wrote his name, huh.
Katrina:  哦香薰
Katrina: Oh, fragrance.
Katrina:  我想买个小香薰
Katrina: I want to buy a little fragrance diffuser.
Lucia: 把一串星星灯直接给房间上挂一圈
Lucia: Just hang a string of star lights around the room.
Lucia: 就完事了
Lucia: And that's it.
Choiszt:  我的天这是我的
Choiszt: Oh my god, this is mine.
Choiszt:  但是倒的过程中就完全没有
Choiszt: But during the pouring, it completely didn't...
Katrina:  哇哈哈这是什么花
Katrina: Wow haha, what kind of flower is this?
Katrina:  哇很直接了当
Katrina: Wow, very straightforward.
Shure: 滴滴往下
Shure: Drip down.
Nicous: 我这儿也有
Nicous: I have it here too.
Jake: 尼玛不照你
Jake: Damn, not shining on you.
Jake: 哈哈哈 15十五号十六号
Jake: Hahaha, 15th, 16th.
Choiszt: 不是我是先移过去
Choiszt: No, I moved it first.
Jake: 不是
Jake: No.
Choiszt:  哎其实没毛病
Choiszt: Actually, there's no problem.
Jake: 哈哈哈多少慢了点
Jake: Hahaha, just a bit slow.
Jake: 只是慢了点
Jake: Just a bit slow.
Lucia: 这有水有
Lucia: There is water here.
Shure: 这里有吧这里有
Shure: Here, here.
Lucia: 昂谢谢
Lucia: Oh, thank you.
Nicous:  傻逼不是你明天搞
Nicous: Idiot, aren't you doing it tomorrow?
Katrina:  没动住
Katrina: Didn't move.
Jake:但是你速度我不知道
Jake: But your speed, I don't know.
Tasha: 没事不用动
Tasha: It's fine, no need to move.
Jake:有变化吗
Jake: Any changes?
Jake: 呵呵很讲究的命名方式
Jake: Haha, a very sophisticated naming method.
Shure:  这个面糊会不会堵下水道呢
Shure: Will this batter clog the drain?
Jake: 呃然后进去
Jake: Uh, and then go in.
Jake: 就这够快了
Jake: That's fast enough.
Jake: 比迈克快多了哎
Jake: Much faster than Mike.
Jake: 迈克也很快
Jake: Mike is fast too.
Shure: 离不开啊你
Shure: You just can't stay away, huh?
Jake: 你可以你可以见很多
Jake: You can, you can see a lot.
Jake: 你可以见到22
Jake: You can see 22.
Jake: 你在我最外层
Jake: You're on my outermost layer.
Shure:  搞定
Shure: Done.
Shure: 全蹦亮跟你讲
Shure: It's all set, I'm telling you.
Jake: 对啊我我觉得不应该这么慢的
Jake: Yeah, I think it shouldn't be this slow.
Shure: 啊搞定
Shure: Ah, done.
Jake: 所以说我得插到GoPro
Jake: So, I need to plug it into the GoPro.
Jake: 就是把那个充电线给插电脑上面
Jake: Just plug the charging cable into the computer.
Jake: 然后开始倒
Jake: Then start transferring.
Jake: 然后每一个一个一个跑
Jake: Then run each one by one.
Jake: 就是原来的方案是推着这个小桌子
Jake: Originally, the plan was to push this small table.
Jake: 然后推着到处跑
Jake: And then push it around.
Jake: 然后我他妈傻逼了
Jake: And then I was being an idiot.
Jake: 哈哈哈太难了
Jake: Hahaha, it's too hard.
Shure: 你再点什么
Shure: What are you ordering now?
Jake: 太慢了又慢又麻烦
Jake: It's too slow, both slow and troublesome.
小黄: 你这个你这个
Nicous: This, this...
Nicous:  喊人来都包不了
Nicous: Even if you call people, it won't be enough.
Nicous:  这不就得一个电脑一个
Nicous: Doesn't each person need a computer?
Jake:对啊
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 不就两两个人
Jake: Isn't it two people?
Jake: 好歹一人一层啊
Jake: At least one per layer.
Jake: 我他妈一人15个
Jake: I'm handling 15 by myself.
Lucia: 要不去搬俩凳子下来
Lucia: How about we get a couple of chairs down?
Shure:  我们一会在上面吃还是下面吃
Shure: Are we eating upstairs or downstairs later?
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
Shure:  火锅
Shure: Hotpot.
Jake:火锅在下面吃
Jake: Let's eat the hotpot downstairs.
Shure: 下面吃是吗
Shure: Downstairs, right?
Choiszt: 所以现在没事是吗
Choiszt: So, nothing's going on now?
Shure: 下面吃
Shure: Eating downstairs.
Katrina:  现在在休息
Katrina: We're resting now.
Lucia: 如果在下面的话
Lucia: If we eat downstairs.
Lucia: 我就在搬凳子下来
Lucia: I'll go get some chairs down.
Jake:好好在下面吃吧
Jake: Okay, let's eat downstairs.
Lucia: 那行
Lucia: Alright.
Jake: 呃我想一下
Jake: Uh, let me think.
Jake: 在下面吃
Jake: Eating downstairs.
Jake: 可以在下面吃
Jake: You can eat downstairs.
Jake: 你出来被拍吧
Jake: Come out and get filmed.
Jake: 你就给点
Jake: Just give a bit.
Jake: 你给点素材
Jake: Give some material.
Jake: 你出来谈
Jake: Come out and talk.
Katrina:  好
Katrina: Okay.
Jake:给你
Jake: Here you go.
Shure:  席地而坐大象席地而坐
Shure: Sitting on the ground, like an elephant sitting on the ground.
Jake: 你这吉他还是被扫拨的
Jake: Your guitar is being strummed.
Jake: 这是一个赛博组啊
Jake: This is a cyber group.
Shure: 是吧哦
Shure: Right, oh.
Shure:  他有自己的生命了
Shure: It has its own life now.
Jake: 对但是他不是赛博的
Jake: Yeah, but it's not cyber.
Jake: 你是赛博的
Jake: You are cyber.
Shure:  那也就是现在就是凭空就有一个人
Shure: So now there's just a person out of nowhere?
Shure:  有一把吉他在这里自己发声是吧
Shure: A guitar here making its own sound, right?
Nicous: 好了这搞的好像没声了都
Nicous: Alright, this sounds like it's all gone silent.
Lucia: 我们差差
Lucia: We are so-so.
Shure: onetwothreefourfivesixseveneight
Shure: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Lucia: 然后我们有几个人
Lucia: Then how many people do we have?
Lucia: 8个人再拿一个
Lucia: Eight people, get another one.
Jake: 9哎9哎9号卡
Jake: Nine, nine, number nine card.
Jake: 你刚刚是谁拿走的
Jake: Who took it just now?
Jake: 9号卡
Jake: Number nine card.
Nicous:  9号在我这边
Nicous: Number nine is with me.
Nicous: 现在是9号啊
Nicous: It's number nine now, huh?
Nicous: 在哪儿点歌啊
Nicous: Where do I request a song?
Shure:  这里
Shure: Here.
Nicous: 有人跳海
Nicous: Someone's jumping into the sea.
Choiszt: ；有人有人相爱有人跳海有人体力走出来
Choiszt: Someone's in love, someone's jumping into the sea, someone's walking out with energy.
Shure: 这就可以点歌了
Shure: You can request a song now.
Shure:  然后加入到歌单就好
Shure: Then just add it to the playlist.
Choiszt:  直接把
Choiszt: Just
Choiszt:  直接把专辑打开
Choiszt: Just open the album.
Shure:  好好好
Shure: Okay, okay.
Shure:  对加入到歌单
Shure: Yeah, add it to the playlist.
Shure:  然后放入到易购里面
Shure: Then put it into Yigou.
Choiszt: 什么里面
Choiszt: Into what?
Shure:  就是比如说那更多那款
Shure: Like that Gengduo one.
Choiszt: 昂我知道
Choiszt: Oh, I got it.
Shure:  然后收藏
Shure: And then favorite it
Shure:  然后到易购里面
Shure: Then go to Yigou
Shure:  想想我们要干什么家人们
Shure: Think about what we are going to do, guys
Choiszt: 修硕来个热舞吧修硕
Choiszt: Shure, do a hot dance, Shure
Nicous: 看看我这个一会给大家还原出来
Nicous: Look, I'll show you all later
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey
Nicous: 学会了吗
Nicous: Did you learn it?
Shure: 学会了
Shure: Learned it
Nicous: 你们赶紧会吧
Nicous: Hurry up and get it
Choiszt: 我会翻绳
Choiszt: I can do string tricks
Shure:  你们会翻绳吗
Shure: Can you guys do string tricks?
Choiszt: 会什么
Choiszt: Do what?
Shure:  会翻绳吗
Shure: String tricks?
Shure:  拿着绳来了
Shure: Got the string
Choiszt: 会翻绳绳子
Choiszt: Can do string tricks with the string
Shure:  咱们不至于这么赛博吧
Shure: We can't be this cyberpunk, right?
Shure:  有没有棉线什么的
Shure: Do we have any cotton thread?
Nicous: 没有没有
Nicous: No, no
Choiszt:  有绳吗
Choiszt: Do we have string?
Shure: 没有
Shure: No
Nicous: 我把这边先过了最右边
Nicous: I'll first go through the far-right side
Shure:  这是你的张璇
Shure: This is yours, Zhang Xuan
Tasha: 好好听啊
Tasha: It sounds so good
Jake: 你房间装扮吗
Jake: Are you decorating your room?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Shure:  我的房间好像没有什么太装扮的东西
Shure: My room doesn't really have much to decorate
Jake: 多少啊
Jake: How much?
Shure:  这个角落真的好好看
Shure: This corner looks really nice
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake: 今今天晚上怎么说
Jake: So, what's the plan for tonight?
Jake: 多一个人能让我多睡好几个小时
Jake: One more person can let me sleep a few more hours
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Lucia: 偷过来玩吧
Lucia: Sneak over and play
Nicous: 把他们介绍介绍介绍
Nicous: Introduce them, introduce them
Shure: 我们
Shure: We
Nicous: 这个口好舒服
Nicous: This one feels so nice
Katrina: 我今天看见他了
Katrina: I saw him today
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Shure: 我们昨天看见他的衣服了
Shure: We saw his clothes yesterday.
Lucia: 去找他玩吧他昨天趴在那个角落里睡觉
Lucia: Let's go find him. He was sleeping in that corner yesterday.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake: 在哪啊
Jake: Where is he?
Shure: 那我们去扒他衣服去
Shure: Let's go and take off his clothes.
Lucia: 可以去找他玩吗
Lucia: Can we go find him?
Shure:  扒他裤子
Shure: Take off his pants.
Jake: 对人家关了
Jake: He's locked himself in.
Jake: 没电了应该
Jake: Probably out of battery.
Katrina: 我看看
Katrina: Let me check.
Jake: 可能没电了
Jake: It might be out of battery.
Shure: 应该没电了
Shure: Should be out of battery.
Choiszt: 没电了怎么办充电
Choiszt: What do we do if it's out of battery? Charge it?
Jake: 插充电宝
Jake: Plug in a power bank.
Shure:  那那有一沓刚才
Shure: There was a stack over there just now.
Choiszt: 所以这种都用充电宝
Choiszt: So you use power banks for these things?
Choiszt:  这个中途断了也没事是吧
Choiszt: It doesn't matter if it stops midway, right?
Jake: 中途断了再录
Jake: If it stops, just record again.
Jake: 录完再没人再看一下时间
Jake: After recording, someone should check the time again.
Choiszt: 好
Choiszt: Okay.
Jake: 巧妙哈哈哈
Jake: Clever, hahaha.
Choiszt: 他看的那个时间是
Choiszt: The time he's looking at is...
Choiszt:  计时器的时间是不是
Choiszt: It's the timer's time, right?
Tasha: 你们在干什么呀
Tasha: What are you guys doing?
Jake:  对对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake: 然后每人都要看一眼
Jake: Then everyone needs to take a look.
Tasha: 可以装饰我的communicate
Tasha: Can I decorate my communicate?
Jake: 啊不不不
Jake: Ah, no, no, no.
Jake: 一个秒表一个精确到后几位的秒表
Jake: One stopwatch, one precise to the last few digits stopwatch.
Choiszt: 那那我怎么知道是就是今天下午
Choiszt: So how do I know if it's this afternoon?
Jake: 呃是不是今天下午命名上面规定了
Jake: Uh, is it specified in the naming for this afternoon?
Jake: 具体时间不重要
Jake: The exact time doesn't matter.
Jake: 时间限制比较重
Jake: The time limit is more important.
Choiszt: OK
Choiszt: OK.
Jake: 就是不要那么具体
Jake: It doesn't have to be that specific.
Jake: 差个5分钟没关系
Jake: Being off by 5 minutes is fine.
Katrina: 这个昂
Katrina: This, uh...
Shure: 谢谢
Shure: Thank you.
Katrina:  这是上一段开了的
Katrina: This was opened in the last segment.
Shure:  这是你的室内设计对吧
Shure: Is this your interior design, right?
Jake:插电了昂
Jake: Plug it in.
Jake: 有电吗
Jake: Is there power?
Katrina:  有啊
Katrina: Yes, there is.
Choiszt: 有啊
Choiszt: Yes, there is.
Jake:  他这像有电的吗
Jake: Does it look like it has power?
Jake: 不像有电的
Jake: Doesn't seem like it.
Nicous:  不是我充的时候
Nicous: Not when I was charging it.
Nicous:  那你等一下我再给你个充电宝
Nicous: Wait a sec, I'll give you a power bank.
Jake: 没电的话
Jake: If there's no power...
Katrina: 在在在
Katrina: It's here, it's here.
Jake: 哦哦对
Jake: Oh, right.
Shure: 我曹
Shure: Damn.
Shure:  你这歌单成分太复杂了真的是
Shure: Your playlist is so complicated, seriously.
Lucia:  这个也没倒是吗
Lucia: This one hasn't been poured either, right?
Jake: 对这个没倒
Jake: Yeah, this one hasn't.
Katrina:  给一张纸
Katrina: Give me a piece of paper.
Jake: 对妥妥的妥
Jake: Yeah, sure, sure.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 呃你命个名
Jake: Uh, you name it.
Jake: 然后大家跟你对个齐
Jake: Then everyone can match it with you.
Jake: 对齐时间
Jake: Sync the time.
Lucia: 这这个纸是可以用的
Lucia: This paper can be used.
Lucia: 然后就可以用了
Lucia: Then we can use it.
Lucia: 算了万一我就随便写一下
Lucia: Forget it, I'll just write something randomly.
Lucia: 就稍微记录一下灵感
Lucia: Just jotting down some inspiration.
Choiszt: 那里好像那里有纸给你拿一个拿一张那个a4纸
Choiszt: There seems to be paper over there. I'll get you an A4 sheet.
Shure:  哇哇哇
Shure: Wow, wow, wow.
Jake: 要因为太
Jake: Is it because...
Jake: 因为没电是吧
Jake: Because there's no power, right?
Katrina:  啊谢谢
Katrina: Ah, thanks.
Lucia: 这个就可以
Lucia: This one works.
Jake: 哎现在多low啊
Jake: Oh, it's so low now.
Jake: 太low了
Jake: Too low.
Jake: 那10%坐一会吧
Jake: Let's sit for a bit at 10%.
Lucia: 我要换个鞋这个不舒服
Lucia: I need to change my shoes, these are uncomfortable.
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Oh, man.
Katrina: 等会等会去看那个小狗我来给他画一个这个简笔画
Katrina: Wait, wait, let’s go see the puppy. I'll draw a sketch of it.
Jake: 哎你这个是挺好
Jake: Oh, that's pretty good.
Jake: 掌握了精髓
Jake: You've got the essence.
Jake: 在画画
Jake: Drawing
Lucia: 不我在想我怎样能把那个
Lucia: No, I’m thinking about how to make this
Lucia: 他这个房间设计的更好看一点
Lucia: room look better with the design.
Jake: 嗯我去
Jake: Hmm, let me see.
Jake: 你这个是啥呀
Jake: What is this?
Tasha: 花
Tasha: Flowers.
Jake:这什么材料呢
Jake: What material is this?
Katrina:  如果是1.5乘
Katrina: If it's 1.5 times
Katrina:  你已经又上了一层颜色
Katrina: You’ve added another layer of color.
Jake: 确实挺牛逼哈哈
Jake: It’s really impressive, haha.
Jake:不给我看
Jake: Not showing me?
Alice: 你在干什么
Alice: What are you doing?
Alice: 你在画你在设计吗
Alice: Are you drawing or designing something?
Lucia: 没有我正在想
Lucia: No, I’m just thinking.
Lucia: 我那个做成什么样的比例比较好
Lucia: About what proportions to use.
Lucia: 我打算拿一个渔网把它挂一下
Lucia: I plan to hang it up with a fishing net.
Katrina: 画画的baby
Katrina: Drawing baby.
Jake: 你知道如果没有你们
Jake: You know, without you guys
Jake: 我现在是什么样子
Jake: I would be a mess right now.
Tasha: 对我没有别的表演者
Tasha: Yeah, I don't have any other performers.
Tasha: 干枯玫瑰
Tasha: Dry roses.
Jake: 哈哈哈有台眼镜的人
Jake: Haha, someone with glasses.
Jake: 对啊他们可不敢当
Jake: Yeah, they wouldn’t dare.
Choiszt:  哦还得给他打开
Choiszt: Oh, we need to open it for him.
Tasha: 用点不常用的颜色
Tasha: Use some colors that are rarely used.
Tasha: 要不然我心疼
Tasha: Otherwise, I’ll feel bad.
Tasha: 还好不常用
Tasha: Good thing they’re not commonly used.
Tasha: 还可以吧
Tasha: It’s okay.
Jake: 啊鼠标有
Jake: Oh, there’s a mouse.
Jake: 只是我不用
Jake: But I don’t use it.
Jake: 我以为你不傻
Jake: I thought you weren’t silly.
Choiszt:  有了有了
Choiszt: Got it, got it.
Jake: 有了你可以用
Jake: You can use it.
Jake: 当然可以用
Jake: Of course you can use it.
Jake: 主要是位置不太大
Jake: The main issue is the space is small.
Jake: 这触摸板确实不太灵密
Jake: This touchpad isn’t very responsive.
Lucia: 算了拿着看吧
Lucia: Never mind, just take a look.
Katrina: 这个
Katrina: This one.
Choiszt: 这个要插什么
Choiszt: What should I plug this into?
Jake: 再来一个硬盘呗
Jake: Let’s get another hard drive.
Jake: 55能快一点吗
Jake: Hey, can you make it faster?
Jake: 也不一定说实话
Jake: Not necessarily, to be honest.
Jake:  就就就三台硬盘
Jake: Just, just, just three hard drives.
Jake: 确实确实多歇一会也行
Jake: Yeah, yeah, take a break if you need to.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Choiszt: 这里面都删了吗导完了就删了
Choiszt: Did you delete everything here? Delete after importing?
Jake: 导案都删了
Jake: Yeah, deleted after importing.
Jake: 导案你看一眼视频差不多对不对
Jake: Check the video, it should be about right, right?
Jake: 一般我们看这个就是大小对不对
Jake: Usually we just check the size, right?
Jake: 对的就没问题
Jake: If the size matches, it's fine.
Jake: 嗯就是分屏啊
Jake: Yeah, it's about splitting screens.
Jake: 一般你看全是分屏
Jake: We usually split the screens.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 12个头对12个屏
Jake: 12 heads for 12 screens.
Choiszt:  哈哈这其他的
Choiszt: Haha, the others.
Choiszt:  这个 都删呗
Choiszt: All of this, delete it?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Choiszt:  对哦删删删
Choiszt: Yeah, delete, delete, delete.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake: 然后再装回去
Jake: Then install it back again.
Jake: 装回到这个里面
Jake: Install it back here.
Jake: 一个屏幕四个屏
Jake: One screen, four screens.
Jake: 有几个人一起一场
Jake: How many people in one session?
Jake: 那个魔力答辩
Jake: That magic defense thing.
Jake: 今天早上
Jake: This morning.
Shure:  十个好像将近十个
Shure: About ten, almost ten.
Choiszt: 十个
Choiszt: Ten.
Shure:  我第
Shure: I was the...
Shure:  不是谁谁自告奋勇
Shure: Wasn't it someone volunteering?
Shure:  就是谁先来
Shure: Like, who goes first.
Jake: 你自告奋勇
Jake: You volunteered.
Jake: 我第二个
Jake: I was second.
Shure:  第一个没没没答上
Shure: The first one didn't answer.
Shure:  哦然后我后面的同学就是我女朋友
Shure: Oh, then the classmate behind me, she's my girlfriend.
Shure:  她电脑突然放不出来了
Shure: Her computer suddenly stopped working.
Shure:  然后借她电脑用了下
Shure: Then I borrowed her computer.
Shure:  然后所以就10点半正好答完
Shure: So I finished answering around 10:30.
Jake: 所以最后他们10个人的话结
Jake: So if there were ten people, when did it end?
Jake: 什么时候结束啊
Jake: What time did it end?
Shure: 十二点多
Shure: A bit past twelve.
Jake:  这么快
Jake: That was fast.
Shure:  九点到了
Shure: It's 9 o'clock.
Shure:  12点
Shure: It's 12 o'clock.
Nicous: 哎等会
Nicous: Hey, wait a minute.
Jake: 谁是红卡
Jake: Who has the red card?
Choiszt:  十号十号十号
Choiszt: Number ten, number ten, number ten.
Choiszt:  啊路路上
Choiszt: Ah, on the way.
Jake: 就是有一些我我用
Jake: There are some files I...
Jake: 就是我手忙脚乱的导出来的一些
Jake: ...hastily transferred to the hard drive.
Jake: 在那个硬盘里边
Jake: It's on that hard drive.
Jake: 我我把我把硬盘给你们
Jake: I'll give you the hard drive.
Jake: 然后还是把硬盘给清出来
Jake: Then you can clear the hard drive.
Jake: 你你你你先整别的吧
Jake: You, you, you work on something else first.
Jake: USB卡比较重要
Jake: The USB card is more important.
Jake: 这就完事了
Jake: That's all.
Jake: 你你可以给它隔热化
Jake: You can give it insulation.
Jake: 运营也行
Jake: Or just operate it.
Jake: 金明珠还在等着我
Jake: Jin Mingzhu is still waiting for me.
Choiszt:  11也没有12 好
Choiszt: Eleven or twelve, okay.
Jake: 金明珠帮我把我的水给我
Jake: Jin Mingzhu, get my water for me.
Jake: 帮忙收点数据吧
Jake: Help collect some data.
Shure: 什么数据
Shure: What data?
Jake: 多多多看看昨天买的东西
Jake: Check out the stuff we bought yesterday.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Got it.
Jake: 一些毫无逻辑的行为硬加一些QA
Jake: Some illogical behaviors, add some QA.
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 你你你就出题
Jake: Just create the questions.
Jake: 好吧你现在就哈哈哈
Jake: Okay, now just hahaha.
Shure:  为什么我们要买这些东西
Shure: Why did we buy these things?
Shure:  白糖是干什么的
Shure: What's the sugar for?
Shure:  玉米淀粉又是干什么的
Shure: And what's the cornstarch for?